it's great to welcome to the program
today Ted Conover who's an author
practicing immersion writing as well as
director of NYU's Arthur L Carter
journalism Institute I've actually
recommended one or two of Ted's books to
my audience in the past Ted I really
appreciate your time thanks for talking
to me so there are a lot of people in my
audience who may not immediately know
what we mean by immersion writing and
some of the work that you've done in
advance sometimes four years before you
will write a book certainly knew Jack
where you actually became a correctional
officer in order to tell the story of
what that's like
in coyotes you actually travel across
the us-mexico border with undocumented
immigrants and and even subsequently
work with them in multiple places in the
United States so first to just kind of
frame it when you start a project like
this
what's the genesis of an idea how do you
think about your relationship to the
subject matter and start thinking about
how you'll carry the project out sure I
guess you could say my approach is to
try to go more in depth than a regular
journalist can I look for a subject that
matters to people maybe it's mass
incarceration maybe it's immigration
undocumented immigration or homelessness
and I think okay what a journalist
another has been able to do to cast
light on this topic and what could I do
if I were willing to spend more time and
get closer get my hands dirty if needed
and often the answer has been I tried to
go beyond the sort of interview a
journalist does right asking the five
W's and all that and spend time living
with somebody else or doing what they do
so
my first book is about railroad tramps
and I was still an undergraduate in
college and rode the rails
I met Mexicans while doing that and
using my high school Spanish
realized they would talk to me and in
fact it seemed open to it and it seemed
open to me hanging out and that became
my my second book called coyotes which
you mentioned and then yeah when I moved
to New York from Colorado gosh 20 years
ago mass incarceration was all over the
news as it is again today and I thought
you know there's got to be a way to get
closer to the subject than just you know
calling up people on the phone or doing
interviews and ended up applying for a
job as a New York state corrections
officer which took about three years to
get and then I worked the worked at
sing-sing almost a year for that book
and the idea is yeah I get closer I'm
not a standard journalist keeping my
distance I'm I'm right in there and you
know sometimes distance is good it lets
you be a little more objective but I
tend to get subjective I say you know
I'm a I'm a CEO I'm scared of this
situation or I'm a CEO the guys around
me are angry and today I understand it I
feel kind of angry myself and and so I I
try to take notes on what it feels like
to be there in the book New Jack and
also in some of the the research I did
preparing for the interview you talked
about the perception that could have
been the one that your your co-workers
at sing-sing came away with when they
learned about the fact that you were
researching and ultimately wrote a book
about your experience there that they
might be mad at you they might not like
the fact that you essentially I mean to
call it it's not a ruse in the sense
that you really did go through the
training you really did work there you
nobody knew you weren't treated
differently because there was this book
coming at the end of the experience but
that maybe you took advantage in some
way that is not okay or that they would
in some way be displeased with
fact that you were there not just as a
correctional officer but also as a
writer for sure
what was I mean what is there a fair
critique to be made that you were sort
of using the resources of training in
order to end up writing a book or do you
find that not to be a fair critique well
you've asked a couple of questions that
last one is did I you know somehow take
advantage of the resources of the state
of New York
just to you know just to be able to
write something about it and in fact I
stayed on the job longer than the
typical trainee does most people drop
out before I did and I stuck with it so
I think New York State got their value
from me it was a good employee
I got good job ratings I tried really
hard to be a good corrections officer
and understand what that meant that's
one of two projects which you could call
undercover because I could not tell
people my full background or my real
agenda which was to write something
about this the other time I did that I
became a USDA meat inspector at a beef
plant in in Nebraska and that was
secretive too and if you do something in
a secretive way you are deceptive and
deception is best avoided in journalism
but there are times when in order to do
something important I think deception is
warranted not all journalists agree but
there was no other way I could
understand the life of a an officer a
guard at sing-sing without doing that
job I had previously actually gotten an
assignment from The New Yorker to write
about SEOs upstate and and then the
state wouldn't let me go to work with
them
they would let me visit a single prison
once for a short guided tour but you
know this is a big deal its Corrections
as the second-largest employer in New
York State or was when I was a CEO and
how could how do you justify keeping the
public out so I felt justified in
getting the job secretly and then you
know every journalist faces a moment of
reckoning when the when what they've
written comes out or what they've
produced on video the subjects like it
or they don't and they say it's true or
they say that's BS it's not really
different when you've done something
undercover people you write about are
still either gonna say that's BS or
they're gonna say yeah well actually
that's true and far and away CEOs said
that book is true you know it's warts
and all we don't look good in the whole
thing but I got credit for doing the job
myself
and and for telling the truth about it
most angry was the state of New York
which put out a press release urging
aggrieved employees to sue me if they
felt I had injured them somehow and I
think the people who felt injured were
the the state corrections bureaucrats
who's who felt I'd snuck into their
their prisons and and talked about it
which I wasn't supposed to do one of the
things in New Jack that comes out which
I think couldn't possibly have come out
if you were just interviewing people is
the sort of many sides of the
prototypical correctional officer in the
sense that there's often conflict about
their views of the system there's
conflict about the views on even
individual inmates as some of the
stories that you tell what else was only
possible in the telling of that story
because you were immersed as a
correctional officer that by
interviewing people simply could not
have been
part of the story I'm really happy you
brought up that example because to me
that is what this approach lets me do is
look at a big fat stereotype like the
guard as bruton or the guard as sadist
and think and ask out loud how much of
that is true and and you're right I
found in some cases gosh that guy's
pretty bad but in lots of other cases in
fact in most cases what I found was
human beings trying to keep something
good in themselves alive while being
immersed in this negative environment
day after day after day like it's a
crummy job it brings out the worst in
them it brought out the worst in me as
my wife observed it showed her my inner
disciplinarian which I had actually
never tried to cultivate but that's kind
of what the job asks you to do is say no
all day long to your fellow human beings
so the to get to your question more
particularly working at sing-sing put me
in a group of officers of color and
there's no way I could have learned the
things I learned about their lives
otherwise I'm I remember the day I'm
talking to the crew I worked with in B
Block it's this giant housing block more
than 600 prisoners we had like 15
minutes outside the mess hall before we
had to start frisking prisoners and a
guy named Alcantara who's Dominican and
lives near New York City described
double parking outside his mom's
building because she was moving and he
had his minivan and he ran inside her
Lobby to pick something up and as he's
running out undercover officers thinking
he's part of a drug deal tackle him and
I heard this a version of this story
like six different time
these are officers of color I work with
who are being pulled over by police on
traffic stops or they're being stopped
by Undercovers in Harlem because they
are people of color and that makes a big
impression you know and I wouldn't have
been able to tell stories like that had
I not done the job myself one of the
things that I took away from it in
hearing you know you described in the
book kind of your personality
transformation as you described and your
wife dealing with it is that maybe there
really is more to this idea that the
focus on individuals in systems even now
like with the unrest and protests that
we are seeing the the focus on
individuals is relevant because people
are people as individuals but we
shouldn't ignore the effect that systems
have and that was a really big takeaway
for me yeah the system makes you act a
certain way let's say you are a person
convicted of a crime who has had friends
of different races you know you're
you're from a place where it was cool
making friends who didn't look like you
well you're going to prison and that
that stuff doesn't fly in a lot of
prisons you have to stick with your own
kind
you know prisons are racially polarized
and then their ideological II polarized
and they're organized by gang and and so
prisoners inmates have to act a certain
way and then so do officers let's say
I'm out an officer who thinks it's okay
to have a conversation with a prisoner
like just you know how we did I mean
that was something you described yeah I
I thought well that should be that's a
good idea right that's how you manage
people you talk to them there's a whole
bunch of officers who who think that's a
terrible idea that that you're gonna
you're gonna get a reputation as the
inmates friend right a guy who won't
uphold the rules and and in fact and
there were some cases like that where
some officers were just
- friendly and you think whoa what's
what's that about because a certain
distance is appropriate but yeah you're
in the system where your uniform
defines how you interact with other
people and and you're one of a group of
people whether you're a prisoner or an
officer you're one of a group and you
have to act in accordance with the
standards of that group and gosh when I
see officers now standing shoulder to
shoulder to repel demonstrators I'm
always thinking okay how many of them
are spoiling for a fight because you can
tell some of them are right you know all
of their hearts are beating bump bump
bump bomb they're like okay is it when's
it gonna start how long can i restrain
myself what are who's gonna stick up for
me
if rock hits me in the head but then you
know there's a whole bunch of them who
are like oh my god let me just get home
in one piece and back to my family and
my my toddler and right I I didn't
really sign up to be in a riot and but
how is how are those people going to act
when when it comes to violence
how will they will they respond to their
training with restraint will they
respond to their you know that their
ancient brain and start firing a weapon
or flailing with a gun the the whole
question of how you act when you're a
law enforcement officer and part of a
group that's under stress is super
important and matters so much today and
and yeah so that's that's kind of the
thing I wanted to to find out about
let's pause the conversation there on
our podcast but we'll have the full
conversation with Ted on our on our
youtube channel so I would like to talk
a little bit of
you're experienced in that you described
in coyotes which I most recently read
now the book correct me if I'm wrong is
for it was published in 86 but it
contains things you did in the early to
mid 80s is that roughly accurate yes
although actually it would be late 80s
it would be now I don't remember I
thought it will not any case it was
somewhere in the mid to late eighties it
was certainly some time ago a lot of
things about immigration to the United
States have changed since then but what
I was struck by was so I I'm an
immigrant to the u.s. from Argentina but
I am white and I came early enough where
I don't speak accented English and I
certainly had a very different
experience than the guys you and and
occasionally women that you spent time
with what was most striking to me from
the book was the degree to which you
were like them in as far as the people
you interacted with in so many ways in
other words as far as people knew
economically indistinguishable going to
work in Arizona at the citrus farm and
collecting oranges and at one point
lemons I believe it was but yet at
almost every interaction you were often
treated differently just on the basis
that you you did stand out in the way
that you were a white American guy and
there was no getting rid of that as
immersed as you word that that you
couldn't get rid of no and you know I
like to blend in and and connect on the
basis of things I have in common with
people but with that book there's no way
I'm gonna pass as a Mexican migrant I
never even entertained the thought I
could that said you know I had just
finished this project where I traveled
for four months on freight trains with
with American mostly american-born
transient people and and there was a lot
of I had a lot of fear in
that experience because a lot of them
you know have their issues there's a lot
of violence there's a lot of addiction
with the the Mexicans I traveled with
that was not the case these are mostly
childhood friends from a little valley
and Kenneth Thoreau northwest of Mexico
City who who were there like whole
people and they're my age and it was by
and large I had a great time with them
and they looked out for me they weren't
you know I connected with a farm workers
group in Arizona and and they felt that
they needed to do right by me by looking
after me so that I've got to say of all
the different groups of people I've hung
out with that was the most fun cuz they
were guys my age you know when you've
done with the day of work you have a few
beers you yeah you're thinking a lot of
the same thoughts and and I'm still in
touch with a whole bunch of them
including that woman
Avon halika who accompanied our group of
seventeen people across the border into
Arizona and then up to Idaho and she's
back home and a bunch of others found me
on Facebook which is pretty cool
so in there's so much about that book
that is so relevant today but for me you
know if I were to recommend it to
someone today given what's going on you
know with coronavirus and questions
about which workers are essential in
which are not in the supply chain of
food and agriculture in the United
States what would be just incredible if
more people understood would be not just
you know as you describe picking oranges
up on ladders where you carry the ladder
and then you put the huge bag and then
you're throwing these oranges into the
bag which gets heavier and heavier as
you're on the ladder just bag after bag
after bag so there's the hard work of
just you go and you buy navel oranges at
a buck fifty a pound
everything that went into that first of
all but the story you tell about how
much work went in to get that job and
this is not an endorsement or attack on
crossing a border you're not authorized
to cross it's merely the empirical
reality that you know you tell the story
that starts in the mountains of Mexico
and takes bus rides and other
altercations merely to get to the border
a multi-day trip through the desert this
is all just to get a job that many of us
don't even understand that seems so
relevant today and it's just it's just
not part of most people's understanding
of what we mean when we say undocumented
workers I gotta tell you it sure
instilled in me respect for immigrants
who want to come here to work to better
themselves things were different in the
80s as you mentioned insofar as you know
it was mostly agricultural workers at
the time mostly men mostly from rural
parts of Mexico the poorest parts it's a
more diverse group now who work in all
kinds of jobs and among them there's no
denying you know are a few bad apples
but overall the people I met made me
proud to be part of a country built on
immigration you know a country populated
by people who chose to come here to make
something of themselves and that spirit
was so clear in the in the people I
worked with who by the way could work so
much harder than me I felt like such a
wuss you know complaining after a day of
picking lemons that that my hand hurt
from the Clippers or my shoulder hurt
from that heavy bag they like haha
Americans are so soft I mean along those
lines
the jobs that I'm trying to think so you
did you did the citrus part of
what would remind me which other because
I know that sometimes you were visiting
places but you weren't working like the
potato farm in Idaho what other jobs did
you work with them yeah well that was
the most extended job I had and the rest
of the time I was mostly traveling right
to get a job with a crew of cement
workers in Houston and called the boss
they had his number and they said yeah
we're gonna go to Houston and this guy
Terry all he'll give you a job and I'm
like well let's see and when he heard an
American on the line
say that I wanted a job too and he said
have you ever done it I said no no but
I'm a hard worker they'll tell you and
he goes uh you know I think I just
prefer to work with the Mexicans
obviously that's not good right I'm an
American citizen I shouldn't be locked
out but um again that's the kind of
story you can tell if you put yourself
out there so that's that's what I wanted
to do that also is by the way a reminder
of when when these conversations happen
about quote dealing with undocumented
immigration the focus on the individuals
rather than the employers seems
misguided in a sense and it sounds like
the cement boss that you're talking
about is a smaller employer but there
are very large corporations that
regularly are doing the hiring of
undocumented labor with essentially no
risk I mean sure it's in the law that
you're not supposed to do it but by and
large the large corporations are not the
ones being punished for that right right
in fact until well for many years after
I finished writing coyotes it was not a
crime to hire undocumented people only
only a crime for them to do the work so
that kind of explained things right
there we've been speaking with Ted
Conover author who practices immersion
writing I've most recently read new jack
and coyotes of his work Ted I so
appreciate your time and I I really
enjoyed reading your books and just
thank you so much for talking to me
today David it's a pleasure thank you